appearance
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's likely that Vladimir Putin has
reconciled himself to the fact that
there are no quick wins to this war you
have any precaution the man who runs the
Wagner mercenary group has said he
expects it to take another one and a
half to two years just to recapture the
rest of donbass the expectation is that
Valerie garasimov the man who runs the
Russian army will launch some kind of
spring offensive what we're seeing at
the moment is very intense fighting
around the town of bakmut that has been
going on for several months with huge
casualties on both sides and it's
possible that the ukrainians will
Retreat from there in the coming weeks
although even if they do that will not
make much difference to Russia's
position strategically and along the
rest of the line you have a war of
attrition with not very much movement on
either side it's difficult to see how
Russia scales that up in any
particularly dramatic fashion there are
concerns in the west that it might bring
its Air Force into play in a way that it
hasn't yet in this war but Ukraine has
also have pretty good air defenses at
this stage so we'll have to see what
difference that will make I think as
long as Putin can keep his land Corridor
to Crimea he might be happy to engage
the ukrainians in a long grinding War of
Attrition in the hope that eventually
the West will Tire of providing support
broadly and publicly yes the elites are
behind Vladimir Putin given Western
sanctions they don't really have any
other option but to sink or swim with
him there are disputes of an operational
character really competition over assets
or over positions but nothing that would
undermine the unity of the elites that
said you have this loud patriotic
ultra-nationalist Camp who make a lot of
noise on social media who are quite
critical of the Armed Forces and
sometimes even of the Kremlin and they
are important to watch you also have
powerful men like Evgeni plagosian the
boss of Wagner And also the Chechen
leader Rams and kadirov throwing their
weight around being critical of the arm
me there's also a snapping up of Assets
Now that Western investors have left the
country it has a slight 90s feel to it
now and that might develop further so
Russia in five years time might look
very different to how it does now
foreign
for Vladimir Putin amongst his core
constituencies so the millions of people
who live in the regions who don't earn
all that much who believe what they see
on state TV is still pretty strong Putin
has created this patriotic Narrative of
you're either with us or against us we
must protect Russians wherever they are
the West is out to get us and those are
tropes that are easy for people to latch
onto
[Music]
they don't know the true cost of this
war they aren't told the real casualty
numbers and they do believe that the
West is out to get them and that they
were forced into it the spirit of
patriotism Burns bright and Putin pours
fuel onto those Flames every time he
gives a speech there you go
will he survive this well it depends how
it goes and bearing in mind he's a 70
year old man and Anything could happen
but at the moment domestically he's in a
pretty strong position people believe
his propaganda the economy is doing
better than was expected this time a
year ago sanctions are a really slow
burn and internationally yes he's
isolated but he's not quite as isolated
as perhaps the West might have hoped if
he loses Crimea then that might be
another question who knows what he'd do
but that doesn't look like me at this
stage he's got a lot of Manpower that he
can throw at this his factories are on
overdrive and people believe that this
is for the Long Haul so it doesn't look
at the moment as though there's much
Prospect for change Mark milley the
chairman of the joint Chief of Staff in
the U.S said that Putin had already lost
strategically operationally tactically
then you can be sure that the man in the
gremlin doesn't see it that way